hey y'all time for the matinee show
three new movies that we saw this week
yeah I think the first one is what which
is in the wood which is in the woods
these are all X we rented these all on
at on Xbox did we not yeah yeah none of
these are Netflix or shudder at all and
they're all low budget Conde Andy type
flicks yeah pretty much yeah well that's
kind of what sets up there on offer and
you know yeah well I like those because
you know that most of the time you know
they're gonna turn out to be at least
decent yeah although sometimes I mean
we've seen some of the trailers because
sometimes we'll go through the Xbox's
yeah well some of the trailers it's like
you can tell that that's just really not
yeah we go based off the trailers yeah I
mean I guess that's what most people do
and this one had a pretty good tone to
the trailer so we watched it and yeah it
was pretty good
all right yeah I liked it now I can see
how all right now I don't really want to
like give too much away so I'm gonna be
really really careful like what I say um
so originally this movie was just gonna
be called stranded alright so they
change the title to witches in the woods
and I like that title but I don't know
if it's gonna give people like a false
sense of like what the movie is gonna be
about yeah because I don't think there
were any witches in it well here's the
thing okay so the the basic set up of
the story is there's a group of friends
and frenemies who are going on like
they're going to like a ski resort I
guess they're gonna go snowboarding or
what have you and they get rerouted by
there's like a truck that's jackknifed
and they there's a roadblock and they
have to go around it and then they get
lost because of one of the dudes in the
party is if of course oh I know a
shortcut and I have a map and
wah-bah-bah and you know how that never
works out so they ended up being
stranded in in the middle of the snow in
the middle of the winter and they don't
have like you know any gear or anything
like that obviously because they thought
they were going to a resort so they're
kind of posed and then various things
start to happen
where okay so that's what I'm saying
about the title is that this movie is
one that is open to interpretation
very much about what happened and if you
don't like that then you're probably not
gonna like this movie what I did like
about the movie is that had this movie
been me okay this is this reminded me of
a movie that we would have watched back
in the 80s or I think the 80s like 80s
low-budget movie but had it been made
back then it would have been on
watchable yeah it's it's um it's modern
although I would say that it does kind
it is
I guess you say it does kind of homage
some of the low-budget 80s classics but
really only in tone yeah you know I'm
talking about yes the the the production
quality and the filmography is far
superior
the cinematography is this is beautiful
to what we had back in the answer the
night like all the snowy woods yeah it's
really gorgeous a score you know the
music and everything was a lot better
than what we had in general for a
low-budget movie and the acting is a lot
better than what we had for low-budget
movies back then but it still kind of
gave me that feeling like I was watching
a low-budget movie yeah but you know I
mean a low-budget horror flick but in a
good way in a good way you know that's
what we grew up with we loved those yeah
um kind of like what [ __ ] you know I
don't want to say you know Roman
Polanski but Roman Polanski was
low-budget movies but they were illicit
like the tenant yeah and and open to
interpretation it was kind of like debt
but a modern a modern version of a movie
like that yeah you know you know I'm
just saying that in the sense why I'm
saying it's open to interpretation is
that if you wanted to read it in a
supernatural way yeah you could you
could do that or you could read it in a
completely non supernatural you're
delusional like yeah yeah like there's
like some other [ __ ] going on like it's
like it's like a metaphorical yeah yeah
that's why that's why I would the only
thing I could equate it to is like the
tenets
yeah never have cuz that movie was like
that yeah it was it really some
paranormal [ __ ] with ghosts and trying
to trying to possess him or was he just
going crazy thinking that he was
the girl that lived there before yeah
you know man and this is similar go
either way go either way so if you are
one of those people that are like that
don't like that type of ambiguity or
don't like that kind of movie it's like
no I want it to be like definitively one
thing or the other then you're not gonna
watch this and I wrote it you're not
gonna like it I wouldn't recommend it
however if you do like these kind of you
know ambiguous type stories one thing I
will say like I said cinematography is
gorgeous the sense of isolation is
gorgeous they filmed this up I do was in
Canada somewhere the characters were
believable the characters that was one
thing that I liked it's like I liked
that all the characters were you know
they have the build up it's just like do
you have it the beginning of a slasher
maybe they're all in a car they're gonna
trip together and there's like banter
between them and stuff like that but it
seemed very natural I also liked that
none of the characters were really
unambiguously good guys everybody had
like some bad [ __ ] going on or some
baggage and then there was like some
tensions going on between like several
of the characters like different
situations like love triangle over here
yes sexual assault claims over here
normally in a low-budget movie
especially you know in the generation we
came up and the characters were all
archetypes you knew exactly what kind of
character it was they were kind of
generic and interchangeable this one is
just more of a shades of grey yeah
that's all the same it reminds me that
it's the kind of [ __ ] that Polanski was
doing yeah and he was doing that before
other people were doing it he left
things kind of ambiguous and it just
kind of reminds me of a different
interpretation of a more modern
interpretation of what Polanski was
doing yeah that's quite a [ __ ]
compliment it is yeah it reminds me of a
Polanski film but it is kind of it is an
artistic movie when you think it is a
low-budget artistic movie yeah that's a
good way to put it it's not but it's not
art house flicks
it's not it I mean there's a lot of
really good tension in it there's some
pretty nasty gore you know like people
get killed and mangled and [ __ ] like
that so it's not like just some
arty-farty kind of end I like this oh
I'm not writing that like as a in a
detriment yeah it was not an RD 40 movie
you could actually watch it you know I
mean
just a casual watcher you do have to pay
attention to it this is all the this is
all the good parts of the movie there is
a little bit of downsides to it yeah you
know the downside was as I thought it
was very dialogue heavy and very
dependent on dialogue yeah cuz you kind
of did need you to pay attention the
dialogue just to get all the underlying
relationships between all of the
characters because if you didn't catch
like a few lines of dialogue you
wouldn't know exactly what was going on
because they didn't Hammer it run it
they just talked about it like naturally
but that's understandable you're dealing
with a movie that does not have a big
budget for special effects so it can't
sit there and just show you all this
[ __ ] yeah they so they have to talk
about it so it was a little dialogue
heavy but you know it was but I think
was handled pretty well because it never
felt like I was watching a play yeah
play is just totally dialogue heavy you
know to me so it did feel like a movie
instead of a play yeah so I have to I
have to I have to give it that is this a
[ __ ] perfect movie no it's not well
very few movies well I think the people
that worked on this movie the director
and the writer whoever produced this or
whoever was behind this movie I think
this is the kind of the this is I think
good I think better things will come
from these people yeah
now this um the director is Jordan
Barker and I haven't seen either of his
other movies I think he made one called
the Martian one called torment the
writer was Christopher Borelli now he is
the same writer that did the Vatican
tapes which is actually on Netflix at
the moment although I haven't watched it
yet okay I think it just came to Netflix
yeah I don't know we need to go I don't
know any of these guys but I'm saying
whoever was responsible for the movie
ultimately in terms of direction writing
and just to get get this suck in tone it
just seems like there's better stuff yet
to come from them yeah this is somebody
that I would just blow off and go that
[ __ ] you know that's a nobody or that's
not gonna turn into anything it looks
like these guys are onto something yeah
and like I said cinematography was great
I really liked like all the shots like
where they were just like all inside the
car and they're like they're talking to
each other and like the cameras going
around the car and they're talking to
each other what if it kind of gave you a
sense of almost like the thing where
you're like trapped in this small space
in the snow
and like with people that don't entirely
trust one another and may not entirely
like one another yeah it's a survival
based move you think that to get into
this Jam and there in stranded in a damn
car the middle snow yeah but there's
more to it than that yeah there's a lot
more going on than that but that's the
basic premise and that's that that's a
good premise yeah and I think with the
limitations of the budget they did well
I think they did you I actually really
um I actually really enjoyed this movie
like I said if you don't like ambiguity
you're not gonna like it because it's
you know it could go either way but I
don't mind that so I thought this was a
pretty damn enjoyable movie so we're it
worth seeing yeah definitely worth
seeing
you
and next what I'm gonna do is call sea
fever
yes sea fever I tell you what this is
Irish move unit yeah well I think it's a
like a bunch of different like European
you know production companies and stuff
had a hand in making this one but in
general most of the characters are Irish
you know the boat has an Irish setting
yeah what's a lot better in Gorgo yeah
yeah looking at the poster and then
looking at the trailer I was going man
this might be something kind of like
underwater we loved underwater yeah
and in some ways it kind of was it had
kind of a weird sea monster theme to it
but really was shown about this movie
was the location they were on this damn
boat and they really are on a boat what
it looks like to me I was convinced that
they were on a ship yeah I I don't know
like it the acting was good the
characters were all good um just the way
it was filmed was good I liked
everything about it except one thing I
just didn't like the monster well here's
the thing I I kind of feel like maybe
maybe this was a mistake of the trailer
because I think the trailer makes it
look a little bit more like a monster
movie which is sort it is but it's more
a pandemic a parasite yeah as movie
almost kind of like a disease movie yeah
which is more but there is a monster but
it's very minimal like you don't want to
see much of it and it doesn't hit any of
the notes a monster movie has to hit
yeah for it to be an exciting monster
movie so if that's what you're looking
for you're gonna be kind of disappointed
in to me it just felt like very watered
down
yeah like well here's the thing and you
were saying this I mean I quite liked
this movie um but as I said I think
approaching it thinking that it's gonna
be a monster movie is probably a mistake
because this is actually this is more
like a low-key isolation disease movie
is what it is and that there's kind of a
monster in there but not like hugely and
it's very realistic that's yet it's it's
the monster in it
could really exist right it's not like
something out of science fiction it's
like something that might actually exist
underneath the ocean yeah that's like
not discovered you know and I mean yeah
and kind of the that first quarter part
of the movie I kind of got the feeling
that I was watching basically alien one
but at sea it did seem very much like
that very claustrophobic
you know with this crew on this boat and
you know there's a lot of tension from
the outset because it's like this crew
like I said such a fishing trawler I
think is what it is and this one crew
the crew on there have been working
together a really long time it's like a
husband and wife there's like an older
lady there's a couple like younger dudes
and they've been working together for a
really long time and then this like a
research scientist or like a student or
something comes along on the ship like
for a particular outing like to do some
research or whatever and she's a redhead
which if you know anything about
maritime legends or anything redheads
are supposed to be bad luck like on a
ship and turns out that that legend
turned out to be true in this case what
what was weird about the movie is that
man for me it was in a way more
disappointing than damn dust right or
was it called sand right of the test
walk the dust work I don't know yeah
dust buster it had a lot of promise and
then when you finally see the damn i'ma
call to monster because I don't give a
[ __ ] to me that's kind of a monster
movie as far as I'm concerned I don't
care what they say when you see the
monster you're like oh man this is gonna
be good and normally what ends up
happening is you know the end up
fighting a damn monster and the monster
keeps upping the ante and every time
you're seeing more and more of it and
it's worse every time you see more of
the damn monster then there's a big
showdown they need to kill the monster
but then it turns out you didn't kill
the monster you gotta fight it again
that's usually how it's supposed to go
and you win eventually and you go oh man
they made it to me that's a [ __ ]
monster movie and if it's not like that
then it's [ __ ] up it's just wrong it's
not a monster movie well like I said I
guess not hidden anything I would not
call this about a monster movie I would
call this a disease mirror pandemic
movie because basically what it is
it reminded me a little bit of that
really good that mockumentary called the
bay which was about its I think it's on
to beer it was like a few months ago and
if you haven't seen it I really
recommend it I'm not hugely into like
mockumentary Zoar found footage or
anything but um that was one of the best
ones that I ever saw where it's
basically just like these little
parasitic creatures that like come on or
to like start killing everyone it's kind
of more like that where it's like this
crew they're on the ship and this
[ __ ] disease takes over that like
makes their eyes explode and [ __ ] like
that
and they don't know what to do like they
want to get back to port
but then the scientists telling no you
can't do that because it's gonna like
spread it to everybody so it's kind of
like a comparison above it they didn't
even do that on purpose for me it was
like watching a really good porn movie
with a whole bunch of really [ __ ] hot
women with all having [ __ ] implants
and that fancy fantastic outfits
I mean it's [ __ ] porn to die for but
sex never happened it was kind of like
that I thought it was gonna be a monster
movie yeah look like it would be a
really good monster but it did it's a
scientific thriller yeah nobody very
strongly of the bay if you guys have
seen it it's you know it's not the
structures not the same but kind of the
tone of it as being like a realistic
scientific parasitical invasion that
type of thing
like is real yeah but it had no because
it's scientific and and because it's
foreign it did not have that American
philosophy where you got a [ __ ] this
monster up you know Tonto you know
that's that's and that you're gonna
fight it yeah
and kill it and win yeah I mean that's
not there yeah this looks like a
difference I'm gonna like again it gets
back to porn without sex yeah I think it
do it was a little um it did drag a
little in the middle but I ended up
liking it overall um I think it
premiered at the Toronto Film Festival
last year and I think it got like pretty
favorable reviews weirdly I was looking
up on Wikipedia IMDB or whatever they
said that initially the role of the the
woman I guess she was the captain it was
her boat
that was supposed to be toni collette uh
which would have been rad because she's
[ __ ] amazing but I guess there was a
scheduling conflict and she couldn't do
it um you know she was in hereditary and
knives out and all that so and among
millions of other movies but um she
would make good at but the woman that
was in it was good all the acting was
really good like you know all the
characters were good um but yeah it's
just don't go into it if you want to see
it it's it's a good movie just don't go
into it it's it's like a parasite drama
is what it is it's a really good not a
monster movie it's a really good movie
about something that isn't very
interesting parasites yeah oh [ __ ]
but he did have a little bit of an alien
vibe in this sense they're really
isolated adults but it didn't deliver
I'm just saying from my point of view do
you ever well yeah I really and just
don't go into it now acting that and I
was pissed because it was all there they
could have done it yeah the difference
was the story all they do is just change
the story and change some [ __ ] around
and change some scenes and add some
stuff and have a [ __ ] climax to it
that was acceptable and that would have
been a good monster movie but just
that's just not what they were going for
so I just no no thanks yeah yeah well
yeah it's like going in there you go on
to McDonald's you want a Big Mac right
but they keep [ __ ] forcing the damn
salad on I want the Big Mac it's a nice
salad [ __ ] you I want that damn seat
we'll see yeah that's that's kind of
probably a good analogy because there's
nothing wrong with salad prep it's just
sometimes you don't want it's not what I
want sometimes you want to write back
right yeah and that's a look like I said
just don't go and I think this suffered
because it's trailer kind of makes it
look more like a monster I just don't
know god how many kids are gonna go to a
movie like this it's not for kids but
the thing is if you look at the
demographics who actually spends money
on movies it's younger audiences yeah
but you know and older people wouldn't
want to see this I don't think I think
other people rather see the monster
movie yeah I don't know I'm older I
guess it depends on the people yeah that
we're talking about but yeah I just go
to movies for escapism
I demand to see some outrageous
something that's outrageous and fun well
like I said I go for lots of different
reasons I like lots and lots of
different yeah so I'm not really do all
that [ __ ] you know oh yes I see I
understand the intent yeah oh yeah yeah
I'm not really into the artsy fartsy
[ __ ] see ya okay you wanna spit you
always pick on me that was a teenager
like like that like I'm like not like
that's not what you're supposed to do
and yours he's always like [ __ ] I used
to do that [ __ ] was a teenager sit there
and just analyze that I didn't move ease
the wall over and over again try to
reanalyze so you not I mean
over you can't like [ __ ] on people for
doing what they enjoy I mean you know
I'll I enjoy making money if I'm gonna
make a movie that is gonna make money
yeah well there wasn't there wasn't a
single titty in this movie you know it's
chained anyway I don't think there was
titties in any of the movies ah we was
there just shits barely acceptable all
movies should have titties [ __ ] right
yeah did you have [ __ ] in them too you
want to we're gonna get back at you
gotta have a female draw you know I
gotta see it too although women don't
usually go to sea they don't care yeah
that's it that's it you're gonna came in
a stream watch them [ __ ] tits and ass
dick everything that we're in our Roman
style civilization you know this is all
entertainment yeah it's on it's on VOD
so if it sounds like something you'd be
into then check it out but it's not a
monster movie so yeah don't be expected
that
you
yeah the third movie we saw this week
this one just kind of popped up in our
recommendations I guess it came out
sometime last year like I think like six
or seven months ago yeah they're still
new new enough so we went ahead so we
went ahead and did it cuz you know yeah
it's up there on xbox yeah we just
thought like it wasn't in the new horror
movies but it was in like the
recommendations for what after we
finished watching sea fever this one is
called the shed yeah we watch this one
because the trailer for it's [ __ ]
radical it's all looks like a laugh a
minute TV a teen monster movie about a
bunch of angst growing up in a small
town with AI roxxxy's and trans am super
[ __ ] people wearing flannel and then
in the trailer they dem catch a vampire
and inside a shed and they're gonna use
it to get even with the you know it gets
their enemies who are a bunch of bullies
at high school yeah so it looked [ __ ]
hilarious when we watched it it's a
different kind of movie it's a little
more serious than the trailer leads
leads you to believe but it's still a
good movie I liked it it was it was an
enjoying watch yeah I had a really good
time with this one
even though um like you said the trailer
makes it seem like a little more wacky
yeah um then you know something more
along the lines of like Tucker and Dale
vs. evil or something like that it's not
quite as over-the-top as that now I kind
of wished it was yeah in a way after
seeing the trailer but it's not that
wacky yeah it's it's actually got kind
of a lot of serious stuff in it
sometimes - I liked it though I still
liked it I did - I think they I think
they pulled it off really well and
actually like after like while I was
watching it I was kind of glad that they
didn't go the more zany wacky direction
because that's kind of hard to do you
know what I mean you have to have a lot
of good comedy writers yeah because I
think if you try to do it and you don't
really know what you're doing you're not
that funny they can seem very forced
yeah um but this one was like actually a
lot more had like some funny moments in
it but it mostly played it straight even
though the premise itself is kind of
crazy characters are kind of nuts in the
movie in the movie though too so it kind
of makes sense
we were traitor yeah we were trying to
figure out yeah there's a woman the
plays the sheriff's good she was like
alien Ward Epps yeah I mean they're
trying to place what year this was
taking place in I think it was some
probably sometime in the 90s maybe mid
90s the late 90s - based on how people
were dressed but they're in certain
scenes and they're going through
neighborhoods the cars in the parking
lots looked like sometime mid-2000s
which might have just been because they
couldn't afford to move on it's an
independent movie yeah um because all
the cars of like the main characters
were like old cars yeah I thought yeah I
thought it was so sweet like 1989 maybe
like nobody had cell phones and made
computers you know they sold like while
I walk Manson yeah he said like a like a
Sony Walkman like we had those in the
late 90s though that's true um you know
although I had a CD disc man by the time
the 90s rolled around some people were
still using with tape though yeah I saw
it I still had tapes that told me I
still record stuff on you know pretty
easily up til you know late 90s yeah so
it's hard to say you know she was
wearing thigh high stockings that's a
90s thing it is yeah so and all the
flannel shirts yeah it kind of led me to
believe that maybe it was around 90 yeah
I was thinking 89 but then I was like
well maybe it's like 91 92 what I did
like about it those it kind of was about
the main theme of it is about growing up
in a place [ __ ] shitty towns in the
middle of nowhere
yeah and they worked I think the movie
worked yeah I did - you like I said it's
got like kind of yes it's a monster
movie in the sense that and I kind of
like that because I watched a couple
other reviews of this and what you know
most of people I watched like bloodbath
and Beyond and stuff and a neighbourly
dug it although they did say they're
like well we wish they'd explained like
where the vampire kind of came from or
why there was a vampire in the first
place and like would have gone more into
like the the backstory of the kid and
his parents and everything but in a way
I kind of liked that the vampire wasn't
explained and I mean it's not it's not a
spoiler alert or anything like that like
saying it's a vampire because they tell
you it's a vampire like in the first 10
seconds and the trailer yeah and in the
trailer yeah
so it's like basically there's a vampire
in the woods you know like there is and
a guy that's walk in the woods who's
actually played by Frank Whaley who was
in [ __ ] [ __ ] tons of stuff TV movies
he was in Pulp Fiction he was a red
dragon he was in School of Rock
there's Evans own TV show there are
several vampires in it it starts out
with one vampire it's kind of like it
kind of like the vampire from Salem's
Lot and that bites a dude but in the
original vampire the Salem's a lot
version of dies quick yeah he just like
gets burned right so it's like a vampire
outbreak they turn quick it's not like
old-school vampires we got to die and
then be very like
they turn into vampires but it does
vampire stuff and they can still talk
and like they still seem to have their
mental faculties yeah just kind of like
and they're kind of like you said they
look like barlow they look they look
like animalistic but still kind of human
so yeah so this guy played by Frank
Whaley he gets bit by the by the vampire
in like the first five seconds of the
movie and because like the Sun it's the
middle of the day and the Sun is kind of
like you know cooking him and [ __ ] so he
has to let go from shade the shade and
then he goes and hides in this shed
which turns out belongs to our main
character and named Stanley who lives
with his horrible abusive grandfather
and so this vampire so it's more it's
less about a vampire I guess as about
look what a teenager who had all these
problems when living in this shitty town
being bullied by all these people what
would you do if you had essentially a
monster at your disposal yeah and you
could kind of do whatever you wanted
with it yeah out of the three movies to
review to review today I'd probably pick
this one I think this is my favorite of
the week as well I really really liked I
liked the you know the the interactions
between the teenagers particularly the
two guys like Stanley and his best
friend Dahmer not Dahmer like Jeffrey
Dahmer it spelled different but um but
the interaction between those two was
really great they actually did seem like
they'd been best friends for a long time
and like the way they hung out all the
acting all the yeah actually the guy
that played Dahmer um he was like that
one scene in particular with him and the
bully and like you know trying to get
the guy to go into the shed and
everything like that that was [ __ ]
great I mean at him like fighting
because there was like a um you know
it's Stan doesn't really wanted like
feed people to the vampire and like
towers like maybe we should feel good
people the vampire it's like these
people suck and also they kind of [ __ ]
so it's like so it's kind of about that
more than about the vampire the like in
the third act it kind of goes a little
bit more like a traditional like siege
style thing where buddy's like you know
making steaks and like hiding out in the
house and the vampires coming to get you
and you know at that point it's more
than one had good music in it I really
did like Nevada good music and the
locations were awesome the locations
were like mundane and shitty and you
know yeah whatever they shot this it was
just very much if he if you like dead
mall videos and stuff like damn damn
bells dead malls yeah it's like that so
it's kind of like a new retro wave kind
of feel to the to the damn movie line
that's yeah that's what made me think
that it was like um you know supposed to
be set like in the late 80s or early 90s
because it had that whole kind of like
aesthetic and vibe to its kind of you
take him back to you know another era
when everything was kind of [ __ ]
boring even a lot of those places are
boring now they weren't really boring
back in the 80's and 90's they had more
traffic in them but you know you go to
those places now like this one some of
those old malls and some of those old
places that were built back in the
sixties you know they're just they're
dead but you can I mean I can remember
being a teenager and being you know
growing up in kind of a rednecky town in
Florida you know that's we kind of dead
yeah that's like kind of all there was
to do it's like you know sitting in the
couch out in the woods drinking beer
with your friends and stuff because
there weren't any clubs or anything and
then you play them all and they're there
they're all there walking around yeah
it's so it's kind of like that sort of
thing so I could sort of like relate to
you know the teenagers the high school
students in this and you can also kind
of understand like when they have like
access to this [ __ ] vampire which
sounds ridiculous but it's like I kind
of like that it's like a ridiculous
premise but they sort of took it
seriously but in a way that the movie
was still really fun and entertaining
yeah without being like zany they all
hate each other and they're fighting
over pretty mundane
because they're from Mountain Illinois
where yeah and they're teenagers
so that was realistic I thought but yeah
so it was a good flick I I really liked
it a lot and it's weird because we
usually just look in the you know new
movie section like in the xbox rentals
like the new horror movies and this
wasn't in there it came up after we
finished watching sea fever which was
the last one we reviewed and then it
recommended that one yeah and I was like
oh well that's from 2019 I was like
that's fair enough so we'll watch that
one and it turned out to be really
really good I think this and I think it
almost has four stars out of five yeah
it seems like it's gotten like pretty
good reviews yeah it's just like a
really entertaining but it's got kind of
like a serious message to it as well
like you know if you were bullied like
what would you do like you know would
you take revenge in this particular way
so it kind of has like a deeper meaning
but you don't like have to like get all
bogged down with that because it's still
like really really fun the other Duty
the other two that we did this week had
more like three and a half stars three
stars yeah this one was a solid four I
think yeah and like you said I think
this was probably I mean I liked all the
movies this week and I really liked
witches in the woods too but I think
this one is probably my favorite one
that we saw this week so yeah if you
haven't seen it like I said it's been
out for a while on VOD I think it came
out like the middle of last year or
something like that we just hadn't got
around to seeing it but uh yeah if you
like this kind of like fun it's not
really comedy really but it does have a
little bit of that tone to it so if you
like that kind of thing then definitely
check it out I really recommend it
you